conques de lambi prière et hambourg
l'adieu festive si caractéristique de la
société antillaise va pouvoir redémarrer
la veillée dernier hommage au défunt
était interdite depuis la mi mars
mise à mal par la crise du coronavirus
la présentation du défunt était jusque
là limitée à une vingtaine de parents
proches 200 personnes pourront
maintenant y assister mais avec quelques
recommandations tout de même port du
masque obligatoire
application des gestes barrières
notamment la distanciation physique et
puis et puis pas de distribution de
collations pas de nourriture ni de
boissons
tout simplement parce que sinon il
serait impossible d'en assurer l'hygiène
léveillé devront donc s'adapter à la
crise sanitaire sans repas ni boisson
mais qu'importe car pour les proches ne
plus important est de pouvoir se
recueillir autour du défunt ces derniers
mois le processus de deuil était
fortement altérée il a manqué bien
évidemment durant toute la période de
confinement
des cérémonies léveillé c'est vraiment
un moment clivant pour l'ensemble des
des personnes qui sont affectées par un
des quelques adaptations nécessaires
pour une tradition bien ancrée en
martinique
certaines comme la retransmission de la
cérémonie sur internet pour les proches
éloigné pourrait demeurer